flight service stations are one of the
most valuable but underutilized assets
that a pilot has at his disposal
these are facilities that can provide a
lot of information and other services to
keep us safe when we fly
in this video i'm going to explain how
to call and get a weather briefing how
to file a flight plan and how to get an
in-flight weather briefing before you
make a cross-country flight it's always
a good idea to get a weather briefing
before you go
obviously you should look at the weather
yourself but getting a good weather
briefing can really help you make good
decisions about the weather and most
importantly the flight service stations
can help you avoid thunderstorms to get
a weather briefing from an fss there are
a few different phone numbers you can
call but most pilots use 1-800 weather
brief before we call i want to show you
a trick that's going to make your life a
lot easier the first few times you call
the flight service station i highly
recommend filling out one of these
domestic flight plans before you do
this is because even if you're only
getting a weather briefing this is all
the information they need from you
before they can give you that briefing
in addition to that if you want to file
a flight plan when you call that
information is right in front of you as
well now this form is available on the
faa's website and all you have to do is
google faa domestic flight plan and it's
literally one of the first things to pop
up
okay so when you call for a weather
briefing the first thing you need to do
is tell them you're a pilot for some
reason other people call to get weather
briefings as well so the briefing they
get is going to be a little different
and it may not have the information you
need next make sure they know that this
will be a vfr flight and that lets them
know that you're going to be concerned
about avoiding clouds and areas of bad
visibility now in order to give you a
weather briefing they either need your
aircraft id number or your name they
keep track of who gets weather briefings
so if you crash and didn't get a weather
briefing before the flight they can
throw the book at you i'm just kidding i
don't know why they keep track of them
but it's definitely something to think
about they also need to know your
departure airport route of flight and
your destination
okay so when you call and ask for a
weather briefing there are three types
of briefings you can ask for an outlook
briefing an abbreviated briefing and a
standard briefing if you're not going to
be flying in the next six hours an
outlook briefing is a good briefing to
get the flight service session will give
you more of a general overview of the
weather you can expect six or more hours
from the time you call they're not going
to be able to give you a ton of detail
if you ask for one of these because the
weather can change quite a bit in six
hours but this is a really good briefing
to start out with now if you've already
checked the weather before you go fly
you may just want an abbreviated
briefing i know that you're basically a
weather expert now since you've watched
all my videos on weather so this is a
good option if you've already checked
things out for yourself and you just
need a little bit more information the
last thing you can ask for is the
standard weather briefing if you ask for
this expect to get all the gory details
of the weather along your whole route of
flight this is a good choice if you
didn't have time to check the weather
before your flight
okay so after you've been briefed on the
weather they're probably going to ask
you if you want to file a flight plan
and if you do now's the time to do it it
is possible to file a flight plan on the
radio but it's better to do it over the
phone so you're not clogging up the
radios we will be using the radios to
open up the flight plan and i'll explain
how to do that in just a second but you
really should be filing over the phone
or online instead of the radios with
that in mind we already have all the
information we need to file right in
front of us because we filled out this
form let's look at the rest of these
things really quick now just like the
weather briefing they need to know the
type of aircraft you're flying but they
also need to know the equipment you have
on board in this example i put a slant
golf because my aircraft has a gps but
here are some other common codes for
training aircraft out there but you can
find a complete list on the faa's
website if you can't find the one you
need
next we have our true airspeed the best
thing to use for this are your poh
cruise tables or a flight computer next
we have our departure location our
departure time in zulu our cruising
altitude and our route of flight as you
can see i'm flying direct next is our
destination then our estimated time in
route if you're flying across country
you're going to want to have your nav
log done before you give them this and
that's because you want to be as
accurate as possible with this because
if you're going to be more than 30
minutes late they're going to be sending
a search party out after you that's one
of the advantages to filing a vfr flight
plan the flight service station is
responsible for starting the search and
rescue efforts if something were to
happen to you in flight next we have the
amount of fuel we have on board in order
to get this number you need to know how
many gallons of fuel you have and divide
that by how many gallons of fuel per
hour your plane burns i recommend being
as conservative on this number as
possible once again they need your name
and phone number in case they need to
get in touch with you they also need to
know how many souls are going to be on
board the aircraft
if you crash and you don't put this and
your buddy gets thrown from the aircraft
they may stop the search and rescue
operations when they find the plane in
you and if you're unconscious you won't
be able to tell them that someone else
was with you next they need to know the
color of your aircraft now down here i
don't actually think this is something
they use this is just a reminder for you
to close your flight plan when you reach
your destination and i'll explain how to
do that in just a minute but you need to
close that as soon as you arrive and if
you don't they're going to try calling
you on this number and if you don't
answer your search and rescue operations
will begin alright you got your weather
briefing you filed your flight plan you
took off and now you've started that
cross country let's call the fss and
open up that flight plan and this just
lets them know that we're on our way and
what time we started the first step in
doing that is finding the right
frequency to talk on to do that first
find the closest vor facility on your
route of flight now usually the fss
frequency is on the top of the vor
information box and the name of that
particular fss is attached to the bottom
of the box in these brackets in this
example you can see that the closest fss
frequency to me is actually above this
fayetteville springdale rogers rco box
and below that is the name of the flight
service station in this example their
name is jonesboro radio let's give them
a call jonesboro radio skyhawk 3148
x-ray transmitting and receiving on
122.55 now there's actually a really
important reason why we make the radio
call this way
as you can see down here jonesboro radio
is actually listening to multiple
frequencies they need to know what
frequency you're on and by telling them
that frequency that'll allow them to
respond to you but take a look at this
vor dme down in hot springs this
frequency has a little r after it if you
see this on top of the box this means
that the flight service station can only
receive radio calls on this frequency
they can't respond to it and that's
probably because they're out of range
anyway that doesn't matter what does
matter is that you have to tune in the
vor frequency on your navigate radios
and turn on the sound in order to hear
their response
in this example the radio call would
sound like this jonesboro radio
skyhawk3148xray transmitting on 122.1
and receiving on the hot springs vor and
that just lets them know that we're
talking on 122.1 and we're able to
listen through the vor remember the r
indicates that the fss is receiving on
this frequency not you
now on occasion you may see two
frequencies on top but only one of them
has an r like this one up at walnut
ridge they do that because if you're
below 5000 feet you're probably not
going to have a good enough signal to
have two-way comms on this frequency
you'll probably need to revert to the
split radio procedures on 122.1 and the
walnut ridge 4-tac now you probably
noticed this really big frequency 255 4.
you're not going to be able to tune that
one in with your radios because this is
a military uhf frequency i just don't
want you to be fiddling with your radios
trying to get that frequency to go in
your radios won't go that high all right
let's go back to opening up that flight
plan jonesboro radio skyhawk 3148 x-ray
transmitting and receiving on 122.55
skyhawk 3148 x-ray this is jonesboro
radio we read you five by five what can
we do for you today yes sir i have a
flight plan in the system for skyhawk
3148 x-ray with a departure of zero
eight hundred zulu our actual takeoff
time was zero eight fourteen zulu
no other changes to the flight i would
like to go ahead and open up that flight
plan roger that 48 x-ray i've got your
flight plan right here i'll get that
opened up for you do you need an
in-flight weather briefing if you do
now's a great time for that for now i
think we're good though no thank you sir
i think we have a pretty good picture of
the weather roger that 48 x-ray you have
a good flight will do thank you so much
for your help and that's how easy it is
to open up a flight plan get that fancy
radio call out of the way so they know
what frequency to talk to you on then
just speak plain english to these guys
they're super awesome and really helpful
so as we get closer to our destination
i'm noticing a lot more clouds in front
of me than what was forecasted now what
i've actually had this exact same
situation happen to me between these
same locations so this is a realistic
scenario where you might want to call
and get a weather briefing so let's find
the right frequency and call these guys
up these guys are itching to help pilots
like us out anyways hmm this service
station over here at fort smith is
pretty close let's give him a call
jonesboro radio skyhawk 3148xray
transmitting and receiving on 122.2
skyhawk 3148 x-ray jonesboro radio
you're coming in loud and clear how can
i help you today yes i'm on a dfr cross
country flight from veneto municipal
airport hotel zero four to north little
rock kilo oscar romeo kilo and i need an
in-flight weather briefing when you call
these guys be specific with the
information you need they can help you
with a lot of different situations
i'm flying vfr and i'm having an issue
with the clouds so i want to be as
specific as possible we are 34 miles to
the northeast of the fort smith vortec
and we're seeing a lot more clouds in
front of us than what was forecasted
we're just needing to know if it looks
like these clouds are going to clear up
as we get closer to north little rock we
would like to be able to land under
visual flight rules copy that forward
x-ray i'll take a look at that for you
it looks like along your route of flight
things are about the same as what you're
seeing there but it looks like things
will start opening up for you as you get
on the other side of the russellville
airport conway regional is calling
scattered at 3 500 with visibility at
five statute miles
north little rock is calling few at 4
000 with unlimited visibility hey man
thank you so much i was starting to get
a little nervous about all these clouds
i'm not sure where they all came from no
problem for at x-ray and by the way
we're not seeing any reported
thunderstorms on your route of flight
and no pirates in that area that
conflict with this report enjoy the rest
of your flight and let us know if we can
help you in any other way thanks
jonesborough so as i mentioned earlier
these guys can help in a lot of
different ways they specialize with
weather but they can help you if you get
lost if you can't get a hold of atc and
all kinds of other stuff
okay so last but not least we need to
close out our flight plan now you
probably already noticed this but this
airport is tucked into some tricky
airspace so the easiest thing in this
case may be to call 1-800 weather brief
and close the flight plan that way but
you're flying with me today so we're
going to do things the hard way and
close it over the radio looks like the
closest fss is once again jonesboro
radio on 122.55
jonesboro radio jonesboro radio skyhawk
3148 x-ray transmitting and receiving on
122.55
skyhawk 3148
jonesboro radio go ahead yes sir i'm
five miles to the west of north little
rock with the field in sight i'd like to
go ahead and close my flight plan
skyhawk 3148 x-ray roger i'll get that
closed out for you thank you sir have a
good day see ya and once again do not
forget to do this 30 minutes after you
land you will be getting a phone call
and if you don't answer that search will
begin for your crash site i hope you
liked today's video if you did go ahead
and let your finger land on that like
button and once you do that watch this
quick training video to keep you on
track for that private pilot's license
[Music]